From PRI, Public Radio International. From PRI, Public Radio International. From PRI, Public Radio International. Public Radio. Public Radio International.
来自PRI，公共广播国际。来自PRI，公共广播国际。来自PRI，公共广播国际。公共广播。公共广播国际。
Erika Yeomans knows when her search began. It began when she saw a photo in a magazine.
艾丽卡·约曼斯记得她的搜寻是从什么时候开始的。那始于她在杂志上看到的一张照片。
The picture is this one. It's this photo with his hand on his forehead and his eyes all squinted up with tears rolling down his cheeks.
照片就是这一张。照片里的他一只手抵在额头上，双眼紧闭，泪水顺着脸颊滚落。
At the bottom of the black and white photo is written in cursive lettering "I'm too sad to tell you." It was ironic. It was charming. And the man seemed unusually expressive and vulnerable.
在那张黑白照片的底部，用草写字母写着：“我太难过了，无法告诉你。”这既讽刺又迷人。照片里的男人看起来格外富有表现力，也格外脆弱。
I just think I'm intrigued because it shows a man crying. And you don't see that image very often. And you don't see a man letting himself have these true emotions. And yet he kind of pushes it away a little bit by sort of writing on there "I'm too sad to tell you." And actually, there he is again. There he is again with his hair longer. You see now, you see the first version with short hair and then the second one with his longer hair. And I prefer it short, out of the two photos. I definitely feel much more attracted to the one where his hair is a little bit shorter. It looks very now, both-- the hair styles are very retro '70s now with guys.
我只是觉得我被吸引了，因为照片展现了一个正在哭泣的男人。你并不常看到这样的画面。你也不常看到一个男人让自己流露出这种真实的感情。然而，他又通过写下“我太难过了，无法告诉你”来稍微排解了一些这种情绪。看，他又出现了。他又出现了，这次他的头发更长了。现在你看到了，第一张是短发版本，然后是第二张，留着更长的头发。在这两张照片中，我更喜欢他短发的样子。我绝对更被那张他头发稍微短一点的照片所吸引。看起来非常时髦，两张照片的发型放到现在来看，都是非常复古的70年代风格。
In fact, the photo was from the 1970s, an art photo by a virtually unknown Dutch artist named Bas Jan Ader. Erika read the article about him. And the facts of his life only enhanced the air of mystery and romance in the picture. He did a kind of conceptual art, Bas Jan Ader, this conceptual art that involved a lot of physical challenges that he would set for himself. In one piece, he was photographed falling off the roof of a house. In another, he falls out of a tree. They're goofy, almost comical photos. But other works of his, like the crying pictures, have a kind of wistful, longing quality.
事实上，这张照片来自1970年代，是一位鲜为人知的荷兰艺术家巴斯·简·阿德的艺术摄影作品。艾丽卡读了关于他的文章。他生平的事实让照片里的神秘感和浪漫气息更加浓厚了。巴斯·简·阿德做的是一种观念艺术，这种观念艺术涉及许多他为自己设定的生理挑战。在其中一个作品里，他被拍到从屋顶摔下来。在另一个作品里，他从树上掉下来。这些照片看起来傻乎乎的，近乎滑稽。但他其他的作品，比如那些哭泣的照片，则有一种忧伤而渴望的特质。
There was just something very appealing about it and sad. And I felt like I identified with that longing. And longing for what? I don't know. A searching for something? What is it? I didn't know. And I wanted to know what he was thinking.
它有一种非常吸引人且忧伤的东西。我觉得我认同那种渴望。渴望什么呢？我不知道。是在寻找什么吗？是什么呢？我不知道。我想知道他在想什么。
And his last piece he did was this triptych called In Search of the Miraculous , in which he disappeared. He was trying to sail the Atlantic in a 13-foot sailboat by himself. And he disappeared, and his body was never found. And a year later, his boat was found capsized off the coast of Ireland, and it was this big mystery.
他创作的最后一件作品是一个名为《寻找奇迹》的三联画，在那之后他就失踪了。他试图独自一人驾驶一艘13英尺长的帆船横渡大西洋。然后他就失踪了，他的尸体从未被找到。一年后，人们在爱尔兰海岸发现了被掀翻的船，这成了一个巨大的谜团。
Well, from the WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass, back for another week documenting life in these United States. And today on our program, admiring someone from afar, trying to get closer to them. Act One, In Search of the Miraculous. Act Two, 1,000 Miles to Miles Davis. Act Three, Stalking Snuggles. And Act Four, 1,000 Women Become Selena. Stay with us, won't you?
这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台的《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯，又回来记录美国这一周的生活。今天节目的话题是：从远处仰慕某人，并试图走近他们。第一幕，《寻找奇迹》。第二幕，《迈尔斯·戴维斯的千英里》。第三幕，《追踪“拥抱熊”》。第四幕，《一千个塞琳娜》。请继续收听。
When Erika saw the picture of Bas Jan, it had been a while since she'd had an adventure. For years, she had been slogging away as director of a theatre company, an experimental theatre company that was perpetually strapped for cash, perpetually struggling to get reviewed and get attention. It was frustrating. She needed a change. And seeing the picture of Bas Jan reminded her that life could be an adventure.
当艾丽卡看到巴斯·简的照片时，她已经很久没有经历过冒险了。多年来，她一直作为一家剧团的负责人辛苦工作，那是一家实验剧团，总是资金短缺，总是为了获得评论和关注而挣扎。这令人沮丧。她需要改变。看到巴斯·简的照片提醒她，生活可以是一场冒险。
I feel hesitant actually saying it just flat out in those words because so few of us carry the idea that life should be an adventure into our adult years. And a lot of people think the whole idea is really silly. But this is what Erika Yeomans believed.
其实我有点犹豫要不要直接用这些词说出来，因为我们中很少有人会将“生活应该是一场冒险”这种想法带入成年生活。很多人认为这个想法很傻。但这正是艾丽卡·约曼斯所相信的。
And Bas Jan, she thought, lived his life as an adventure. He was handsome, sensitive looking, and he died for his art. And she decided she was going to find out everything about him, make a film or a document of some kind, even though she had never done anything like this before. She was about to turn 30. It was time for a rite of passage.
而巴斯·简，她认为，正是把生活当作一场冒险来过。他英俊、敏感，并为艺术而死。她决定要找出关于他的一切，制作一部电影或某种文档，尽管她以前从未做过类似的事情。她即将30岁了。这是人生仪式的时刻。
Birthdays, certain birthdays are supposed to  be these big moments. They're supposed to be these big, pivotal moments in your life. And when I was 13, I had a birthday party called Farewell to Childhood, which I had all my girlfriends come over, and we had to dress like five year olds. And when I think about it, it's really kind of a sick thing. And it's embarrassing that I'm even talking about it, but who cares?
生日，某些生日注定是重要的时刻。它们被认为是生命中重大的转折点。在我13岁时，我办了一个名为“告别童年”的生日派对，我让所有的闺蜜都过来，我们必须打扮得像五岁小孩。现在想起来，这真是件挺变态的事。说出来都觉得尴尬，但谁在乎呢？
So at 13, I had this conceptual birthday party, basically, a performance conceptual birthday party. And then I had to have the whole thing costumed and done, because I had to get over my childhood. And so I think 30 was a big year for me, because I kept thinking prior to 30 that something was supposed to happen when you're 30. I don't know what, but something.
所以13岁那年，我办了这个概念生日派对，基本上是一个行为艺术性质的概念生日派对。我还必须把整场活动的服装和细节都搞定，因为我得告别我的童年。所以我认为30岁对我来说是一个重要的年份，因为在30岁之前，我一直觉得人到30岁时应该会发生点什么。我不知道是什么，但就是应该有什么。
Erika tracked down Bas Jan's widow in Los Angeles and decided to make a pilgrimage. And rather than fly from Chicago, which she couldn't afford anyway, she decided she was going to drive. It would be more like Bas Jan, she thought, more a test of will and physical endurance. And events conspired to make it more of a test. Her employer wouldn't give her much time off, so she would actually have to do the drive in two days, not three or four, which it usually takes.
艾丽卡在洛杉矶找到了巴斯·简的遗孀，并决定进行一次朝圣。她没有选择从芝加哥飞过去（反正她也负担不起），而是决定开车前往。她想，这会更像巴斯·简的风格，更像是一种意志和体力的考验。而发生的事情让这变成了一场真正的考验。她的雇主不给她太多假期，所以她必须在两天内完成这段车程，而不是通常需要的三到四天。
Part of my drive out there to LA in some stupid small way was my attempt to be by myself on a journey that, not that it has risk tied to it at all, and it's not really an athletic feat. To drive a couple of days in a beat-up car by myself with a tape recorder and try to figure out if I'm going to be able to discover anything about myself, which I don't know if I did or not. But I was sort of talking to the tape player as if it was, at first, my driving partner, and then second, it became like my therapist. And so then it became a journal by the 48th hour. It became like my journal.
去洛杉矶的车程，在某种愚蠢的小层面上，是我试图独自踏上一段旅程，并不是说这段旅程有什么风险，也不算是什么运动壮举。独自开着一辆破车，带着录音机，试图弄清楚我是否能发现关于自己的什么东西——我不知道我到底有没有做到。但我最初是把录音机当成我的驾驶伙伴，后来它就变成了我的心理医生。到了第48个小时，它就像我的日记本一样。
Well, I've seen it all. My arm is peeling. My driving arm is peeling. My windshield wipers don't work. It's foggy, and it's snowing. And I'm thinking about thick lips.
好吧，我算是看透了。我的手臂在脱皮。开车的那只手臂在脱皮。雨刮器坏了。有雾，还在下雪。我在想那些厚嘴唇。
[SCREAMING] Aah! Come on, car.
[尖叫] 啊！快点，车子。
When I was 18 and 19, I was like a Junior Mint.
当我18、19岁的时候，我感觉就像一颗薄荷糖。
For my life, the way I've jumped around to so many things, from so many different relationships-- Here I am 30, and I'm still not making money at what I want to do.
回望人生，我跳跃着尝试了那么多事情，经历过那么多不同的关系……现在我30岁了，在我想做的事情上还是赚不到钱。
I started to suffer from a real sadness. When I was recording myself, my thoughts, late at night, it started to get very depressing.
我开始遭受一种真正的忧伤。深夜录音时，我的想法开始变得非常消沉。
Because the way I'm doing it is backwards, the way I've done everything. And so I'm thinking everything will come to a fruition when I'm dead, like, when I'm 70 years old.
因为我做事的方式是倒着来的，我做所有事的方式都是如此。所以我认为一切都要等我死了，比如70岁的时候才能开花结果。
And I kept thinking that this was all wrong. And I kept comparing it to Bas Jan. Like how is this adventurous? How is this romantic? What am I trying to teach myself? How am I supposed to grow from this? I'm tired. I've had too much coffee. I've had too many cigarettes. I haven't eaten anything that's healthy. Everything has been in cellophane. It's like this whole thing of doubt, doubt, doubt, doubt, doubt and not knowing why I'm there. And I'm stuck. I can't fly from wherever I am in the middle of Missouri or New Mexico. I have to finish it.
我一直觉得这一切都错了。我一直在拿自己跟巴斯·简比。这怎么算冒险？这怎么浪漫？我到底想教自己什么？我该怎么从这件事中成长？我累了。咖啡喝太多了。烟抽太多了。没吃过什么健康的东西。所有东西都裹在玻璃纸里。这就像一种充满怀疑、怀疑、怀疑、怀疑，而且不知道自己为什么在那里的状态。我被困住了。我不能从密苏里州或新墨西哥州的中部飞走。我必须完成它。
Slow down. OK. Wahoo, wahoo, wahoo. I love this car. Please make it. I love you, car. [SINGING] Driving a steep hill. Whoa. Where are the cowboys and the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
慢下来。好的。喔呼，喔呼，喔呼。我爱这辆车。请撑住。我爱你，车子。[唱歌] 在陡坡上行驶。哇。牛仔和那些[难以辨认]在哪里？
If you ask Erika how she pictured Bas Jan's trip, his transatlantic trip, in his 13-foot boat, she answers without pausing.
如果你问艾丽卡她是如何想象巴斯·简那次横跨大西洋的13英尺小船之旅的，她会毫不犹豫地回答。
I envisioned him catching his fish off the side of the boat and having a little mock up barbecue pit and grilling his fish and having his fresh water supply, eating very little, fasting for a lot of it, and writing a lot in his journals. And perhaps he was going through questioning things, but I don't think he was doing it in such an alarmist way and a melodramatic way that I certainly sounded on the tapes.
我想象着他在船边捕鱼，做了一个简陋的烧烤架烤鱼吃，带着新鲜水源，吃得很少，大部分时间都在禁食，还在日记里写了很多东西。也许他在质疑某些事情，但我认为他不会像我在录音带里听起来那样，以一种危言耸听且夸张的方式进行。
[SINGING] I don't care if my bright blue lights are on, because I need to see. See where I'm going to nowhere.
[唱歌] 我不在乎我的亮蓝色车灯是否亮着，因为我需要看清。看清我正要去往虚无的地方。
Erika drove 15 hours a day for two days. And the third day, things melted down. She barely ate, smoked nonstop. And though she had told her friend Margy that she'd arrive at Margy's house around 9:00, she didn't hit the nether-region outskirts of Los Angeles until 9:00, which may not seem like a big deal.
艾丽卡连续两天每天开车15小时。到了第三天，情况崩溃了。她几乎没吃东西，不停地抽烟。虽然她告诉朋友玛吉她会在9点左右到达，但直到9点她才抵达洛杉矶那一片荒芜的郊区，这看起来可能没什么大不了。
It's millions of lanes of roads whipping around. It's a Friday night, which of course, you know-- I pretend like there's not going to be any traffic. And of course, there was bumper to bumper traffic, cars going really fast. And I'm just driving along. And I start to feel really woozy. And I get woozier as I go on.
那是几百万条车道的道路在交织。这是周五晚上，当然，你知道的……我假装不会有交通拥堵。但当然，车流拥挤不堪，车辆行驶得飞快。我正开着车，开始感到头晕眼花。而且随着驾驶的进行，我越来越晕。
And as I'm getting into the actual city, and I'm looking for the exit for Margy's place, I start to have a panic attack, where I know I'm passing out. I've never passed out in my entire life. I've never ever even experienced that feeling. And here I was, and I know I was passing out. And I couldn't stop my heart from pounding. I couldn't stop myself from-- just either I was going to vomit or I was going to pass out. And I started to panic.
当我进入市区，正在寻找去玛吉家的出口时，我开始恐慌发作，我知道我要昏过去了。我这辈子从来没昏过去过。我甚至从未体验过那种感觉。当时我知道我要昏过去了。我无法阻止心脏剧烈跳动。我无法控制自己——要么我要呕吐，要么我要昏倒。我开始恐慌。
And so I was shaking, trying to get off this freeway with cars whipping around me. At this point, I was going about 30 miles per hour. And I wasn't about to go any faster, because I was really frightened. I was completely paralyzed. I couldn't get over to the exit. I finally weaved my way around with people honking at me, and they know I'm a tourist. They see my plates from Illinois. And I know they're saying all these things. I'm waiting for the gun to come out.
我浑身发抖，试图开下高速公路，周围全是飞驰的汽车。此时我大概以每小时30英里的速度行驶。我不想再开快了，因为我真的很害怕。我彻底瘫痪了。我无法变道去出口。最终我绕了过去，周围的人对我按喇叭，他们知道我是游客。他们看到了我伊利诺伊州的牌照。我知道他们在说什么。我在等待有人拔枪。
I get off the exit. And I'm in some neighborhood that looks really desolate. It looks really scary. It's really dark. There are no streetlights. And I start weeping. And I'm on the side of the street, just thinking I'm going to sleep here tonight. I'm never going to find Margy's house. I was completely, completely, utterly frightened, didn't know what I was going to do. I pumped up myself. I started to breathe, breathe, breathe. I ate some peanuts. That was all I had in the car.
我下了出口。身处一个看起来非常荒凉的社区。看起来真的很可怕。天很黑。没有路灯。我开始哭泣。我停在路边，想着今晚就在这儿睡了。我永远也找不到玛吉的家了。我彻底地、完全地陷入了恐惧，不知道该怎么办。我给自己打气。开始深呼吸，深呼吸，深呼吸。我吃了一些花生。那是车里仅有的东西。
And so I got back on the freeway. And meanwhile, during this time, I'm in my car and I keep hallucinating that I'm melting in my car and that my back of my car is melting into the freeway. And so I keep--
我回到了高速公路上。与此同时，在那段时间里，我一直在车里产生幻觉，觉得我正在融化在车里，车的后部正在融进高速公路。所以我一直……
Hours late, she finally pulled over and called Margy, who came and retrieved her in her pajamas. The next morning, Erika didn't want to look at her car, though she had to.
迟到了几个小时后，她终于停下车，给玛吉打了电话，玛吉穿着睡衣出来把她接走了。第二天早上，艾丽卡不想看她的车，尽管她必须面对。
And I went outside and I noticed that my back rear tire had blown. And that was why I was hallucinating. I wasn't hallucinating. Because my tire had blown and that's what was making me feel like I was melting into the freeway.
我走出去，注意到后轮胎爆了。那就是我产生幻觉的原因。我没产生幻觉。因为我的轮胎爆了，那才是我感觉自己正在融入高速公路的原因。
On their face, the facts of Erika's adventure do not seem like the stuff of myth. A car drive three days long on the interstate highway system. But what's remarkable about her story is that through sheer force of will, she turned it into the right of passage and test of endurance that she had wished for when she set out. And once she recovered the next day, she called Bas Jan's widow, Mary Sue, and headed out to meet her.
从表面上看，艾丽卡的冒险经历似乎算不上神话。只是在州际公路上开了三天的车。但她故事的非凡之处在于，凭借纯粹的意志力，她将这段经历变成了一场她出发时所期待的成年仪式和耐力测试。第二天恢复后，她给巴斯·简的遗孀玛丽·苏打了电话，动身去见她。
I was wearing these very, very, very fluorescent yellow cigarette pants, my army combat boots, and my gas station jacket from the '50s, a very in jacket. I thought I'd fit in with the scene and this art community. At Bergamot Station, there are supposed to be all of these galleries. So I figured there would be a lot of groovy people. And I wanted to look as groovy as I could.
我当时穿着那条非常、非常、非常荧光黄的香烟裤，战斗靴，还有那件50年代的加油站夹克，那是一件很时髦的夹克。我以为我会融入那个场景和艺术圈。在伯格莫特车站，那里应该有很多画廊。所以我认为会有很多时髦的人。我想让自己看起来尽可能时髦。
Mary Sue liked Erika and answered anything she wanted to know. And some of what she said was very different from Erika's pretty picture of Bas Jan as an ideal man, a romantic art hero.
玛丽·苏喜欢艾丽卡，并回答了她想知道的任何事情。其中一些内容与艾丽卡心目中那个完美的巴斯·简——那个浪漫的艺术英雄——的形象大相径庭。
I went through the rudimentary questions, at this point, of trying to figure out what did he sound like? How did he talk? Was he political? Was he not? And there were these very short answers to these things. But after about an hour or so of talking, she started to explain to me that he wasn't this perfect, beautiful creature. Because I kept saying, he's gorgeous.
我按照基础问题过了一遍，试图弄清楚他说话的声音是什么样的？他怎么说话？他有政治倾向吗？他有没有？这些问题都有很简短的回答。但在聊了一个小时左右后，她开始向我解释，他并不是那个完美、美丽的生物。因为我一直说，他太迷人了。
And that's when she sort of said, "I can't paint him that pretty, though." Dot, dot, dot. There were problems. And that's when she started to talk about open relationships. And we sort of had a girl talk about open relationships and how they don't work and about the pain that was involved in her marriage.
那时她说了句：“但我不能把他描绘得那么美好。”省略号。存在一些问题。那时她开始谈论开放式关系。我们就像女孩子一样聊了开放式关系，聊了它们为何行不通，以及她婚姻中经历的痛苦。
What happens when you admire someone from afar, partly because they seemed so sensitive and tragic, and then you find out they were sometimes kind of a jerk? In this case, Erika tenaciously held on to her picture of Bas Jan as a romantic, feeling man. And if you ask Mary Sue, she says there's something lovely about that.
当你因为某人看起来敏感又悲剧而从远处仰慕他们，结果却发现他们有时是个混蛋，会发生什么？在这种情况下，艾丽卡固执地坚持着她心目中那个浪漫、感性的巴斯·简的形象。如果你问玛丽·苏，她说那种执着很可爱。
Yes, I'm sure Erika does have a romanticized view of who Bas Jan was and what he was, of course, like. I think, however, that's just perfect. That's what Bas Jan would have liked more than the real picture. I'm sure he wouldn't want me to explain too completely all the details.
是的，我敢肯定艾丽卡对巴斯·简是谁以及他是什么样的人有浪漫化的看法。但我觉得那很完美。那正是巴斯·简比起真实形象更愿意看到的。我敢肯定他不会希望我把所有的细节都解释得太清楚。
Now, one of the oddest things about this whole story is that Erika sees Bas Jan as a purer artist than she is, a truer artist. When in reality, she labors, mostly in obscurity, following a vision that's completely idiosyncratic, completely her own. A typical show of hers is filled with odd, striking images, lots of strenuous movement, elliptical dialogue, no story. Some shows seem to have an unusual number of people throwing themselves on the floor. The shows can be hard to sit through. But from start to finish, they are clearly a labor of love and a labor of obsession. But to hear her talk about it, she has sold out compared with Bas Jan.
现在，整个故事中最奇怪的事情之一是，艾丽卡认为巴斯·简是一位比她更纯粹的艺术家，更真实的艺术家。而事实上，她一直在默默无闻地劳动，追随一个完全独特的、完全属于她自己的愿景。她的典型演出里充满了古怪、引人注目的意象，大量的剧烈运动，晦涩的对话，没有情节。有些表演里人们摔倒在地面的次数多得异常。演出可能很难坐得住。但从头到尾，它们显然是爱的结晶和痴迷的劳作。但听她自己说起来，与巴斯·简相比，她已经向市场妥协了。
He was more concerned about-- I don't want to say art for art's sake. But he was more interested in what he was doing to himself physically and mentally by putting himself in these images and doing these different tasks. And I don't think he was that worried about if he was going to be a big famous artist, or if he was going to be a successful artist, because he didn't even take care of the work that he had. After he died, they can't even find a lot of his work, because it got damaged in a garage, because they didn't really take care of it.
他更关注——我不想说是为艺术而艺术。但他更感兴趣的是，通过把自己置身于这些影像中并执行这些不同的任务，他对自己进行了怎样的身心磨练。我不认为他在意自己会不会成为大名鼎鼎的艺术家，或者会不会成功，因为他甚至没去打理自己的作品。他去世后，他们甚至找不到他的大部分作品，因为作品在车库里受损了，因为他们并没有真正照顾它们。
Kristine McKenna writes about art for the Los Angeles Times. And she spoke with Erika about Bas Jan several times during Erika's visit.
克里斯汀·麦肯纳为《洛杉矶时报》撰写艺术评论。艾丽卡访问期间，她曾多次与艾丽卡谈起巴斯·简。
This image of him as pure has more to do with something Erika needs than it has to do with the reality of him. Because Erika really is every bit the artist Bas Jan was in terms of intensity and single-mindedness. I'm not an authority on him, but I do know that he was just another guy hustling in LA like everybody else.
将他视为纯粹，与其说是因为他真实的样子，不如说是艾丽卡自身的需求。因为论强度和专注度，艾丽卡绝对和巴斯·简一样是一位真正的艺术家。我不是他的权威，但我知道他和其他在洛杉矶打拼的人一样，只是个普通人。
Basically, I got the impression that she was just completely romantically enchanted with him. And I don't know if she was really even looking for the facts of his life when she came out. It seemed more like some kind of mystical quest. And it was a very short history that he wrote. And that leaves her a lot of room to embellish it.
基本上，我的印象是她被他彻底地、浪漫地迷住了。我不知道她来这里时是否真的在寻找他生平的真相。这看起来更像是一种神秘的探求。他写下的历史非常短暂，这给了她很大的发挥空间来润色。
But I have to add. I was very moved by this whole trip that she made. I can totally understand it. Because yeah, I thought there was something really beautiful about it. I mean, she was the pure one. She's more pure than he was, I'm sure. There's something so innocent in her vision of him and her quest to come out here and get I don't know quite what.
但我必须补充一点。我被她完成的这段旅程深深打动了。我完全能理解。因为是的，我觉得这里面有非常美的东西。我是说，她才是那个纯粹的人。我敢肯定，她比他更纯粹。她对他的憧憬，以及她来到这里寻找某种连她自己都说不清的东西，有一种如此天真的美。
And then in the face of all the evidence that I feel she probably came up with here, she went back home with the same vision. I mean, that's really kind of stubborn innocence. And it's pure in that there's no way she's going to make money off this. She's not going to end up getting a date with the guy because he's dead. So she gains the purity of the obsession.
即使面对所有她可能已经发现的证据，她还是带着同样的愿景回了家。我是说，那真的是一种固执的天真。这种纯粹在于，她绝不可能通过这个赚钱。她也不会因为那个人已经死了而和他约会。所以她获得了那种痴迷带来的纯粹。
Erika Yeomans collected footage from old Hollywood films and from Mary Sue to make a movie about Bas Jan. Her goal was to finish the movie by the time she was 33, the same age Bas Jan was when he set out on the ocean and disappeared. The film she made, In Search of Bas Jan's Miraculous , has played in galleries in New York and Amsterdam.
艾丽卡·约曼斯收集了老好莱坞电影和玛丽·苏提供的片段，制作了一部关于巴斯·简的电影。她的目标是在33岁时完成这部电影，那正是巴斯·简出发横渡大洋并失踪时的年纪。她制作的电影《寻找巴斯的奇迹》曾在纽约和阿姆斯特丹的画廊放映。
Act Two, Meet Your Hero. So what if you idolize someone and then finally do get close to them, actually become their friend? What happens to the romantic dream that you had of them? Well, Quincy Troupe first heard of Miles Davis back when Troupe was just a teenager.
第二幕，遇见你的英雄。如果你崇拜某人，最终却真的走近他们，真的成了他们的朋友，会怎样？你对他们怀有的浪漫梦想会发生什么？嗯，昆西·特鲁普第一次听说迈尔斯·戴维斯时，他还只是个少年。
I was in this all-white high school. It was 3,500 kids, and there was only eight black kids that went to this school. And so I was trying to find some way to be hip at that time.
我在那所全白人的高中。那里有3500个孩子，却只有8个黑人学生。所以我那时想找各种方法让自己显得很酷。
Troupe was in East St. Louis, and Miles was far, far away. Part of what was appealing about Miles was the fact that he had begun in St. Louis himself and had gotten out. And of course, Miles was a blueprint for hipness.
特鲁普在东圣路易斯，而迈尔斯离他非常遥远。迈尔斯之所以吸引人，部分原因是他自己也是从圣路易斯起步并离开那里的。当然，迈尔斯是“酷”的蓝本。
I was in a fish-fry place. And I saw these four black guys sitting in this booth eating jack salmon sandwiches and dinners with dark glasses on and hats and their hair was conked and everything. So I thought they looked pretty hip. So I went and got my sandwich and sat behind them. And at that time, they were talking about this homeboy from East St. Louis. And he was in New York City, and he was doing all these great things and playing all this great music and had played with Charlie Parker. Who I didn't know any of this.
我在一家炸鱼店。看到四个黑人小伙坐在卡座里，戴着墨镜，戴着帽子，梳着油头，吃着三明治和晚餐。我觉得他们看起来很酷。于是我去买了三明治，坐在他们后面。当时，他们正在谈论那个来自东圣路易斯的“老乡”。他正在纽约市做着了不起的事情，演奏着精彩的音乐，还和查理·帕克一起演出过。当时的我对这些一无所知。
And they said, Miles Dewey Davis. Miles Davis. His name is Miles Davis. And they went up to the record player and put in some money and played "Donna Lee." And I remember listening to "Donna Lee." And I said, wow. I hadn't liked jazz up until that point. I was about 14, 15 years old. I was into Johnny Ace and Chuck Berry and that kind of music, rhythm and blues. And when I heard this music, for some reason-- they played it twice. And the second time, it kind of went straight to my heart. I can't explain why it went straight to my heart, but I loved the music.
他们说，迈尔斯·杜威·戴维斯。迈尔斯·戴维斯。他的名字叫迈尔斯·戴维斯。他们走到唱片机前投了钱，放了一首《Donna Lee》。我记得听《Donna Lee》的感觉。我说，哇。在那之前我并不喜欢爵士乐。我当时大约14、15岁。我喜欢约翰尼·艾斯、查克·贝里那种节奏布鲁斯音乐。当我听到这首曲子时，不知为何——他们放了两遍。第二遍的时候，它直接钻进了我的心里。我解释不清楚为什么，但我爱上了这段音乐。
And I sat there, and they sat there for about an hour. And then they left. And when they left, I remember going up to the record player. And I had about $0.30 or something. It was a nickel to play those records. And I went up there, flipped through all those names, and found Miles Davis' name and played "Donna Lee." And I played "Donna Lee," then I played another one.
我坐在那儿，他们坐了大约一个小时。然后他们走了。他们走后，我记得走到唱片机旁。我当时大约有30美分。投币放一首歌要一个镍币。我走过去，翻遍了所有的名字，找到了迈尔斯·戴维斯的名字，放了《Donna Lee》。我放了《Donna Lee》，又放了另一首。
That's when I first heard Miles Davis. And then after that, my cousin told me how hip he was and showed me pictures of him and how clean he was. I started seeing how well he dressed and what great style he had.
那时我第一次听迈尔斯·戴维斯的音乐。后来，表亲告诉我他有多酷，还给我看他的照片，看他有多讲究。我开始注意到他穿得多好，风格多棒。
How clean he was?
他有多讲究？
Yeah. We used to say he was "clean as a broke dick dog," which was a saying that came out of St. Louis. And so I said, wow, this is a guy that I really love. So I started really listening to his music at that time. And it kind of changed my life. And then I found some other friends who had been listening to him for a while. And I kind of left my other friends and started listening to Miles and hanging out with them. And we used to sit up in this stands at Sumner High School and say we were going to run away to New York and be like Miles Davis.
是的。我们以前常说他“干净得像只破烂狗”，那是圣路易斯的一句俗话。所以我说，哇，我真的爱死这家伙了。所以那时我开始真正听他的音乐。这改变了我的生活。我找到了一些也听他音乐的朋友。我离开了其他朋友，开始和他们一起听迈尔斯的歌。我们常坐在萨姆纳高中的看台上说，我们要私奔去纽约，成为像迈尔斯·戴维斯那样的人。
So I remember the first time he came to St. Louis. There was all this big buzz about him coming to play there. And I had doctored up my draft card, and changed all the dates and everything, so I could be old enough to get into the club. And I remember going to the pawn shop and getting these great suits and these Church's shoes, which were too small for my feet. They were those really hip English shoes. And I had this big Chesterfield hat, and I was really clean. But my feet hurt. And my feet hurt because the shoes were too small. The shoes were too small.
我记得他第一次来圣路易斯的时候。他要来演出的消息传得沸沸扬扬。我伪造了我的征兵卡，改了日期，好让自己看起来够大，能进俱乐部。我记得我去当铺买了很棒的西装和Church’s皮鞋，虽然鞋子对我来说太小了。那是那种很酷的英式鞋。我戴着切斯特菲尔德礼帽，看起来非常讲究。但我的脚很疼。因为鞋子太小了。鞋子太小了。
So I go to Peacock Alley with some friends of mine. And we get in. The guy kind of looked at me and said, are you really-- because I was really young looking. But he let me in, finally. He just let me in. And when that band hit, they were so fantastic. They were so fantastic. And Miles was so clean. He was so clean and so hip that I was just mesmerized.
我和朋友们去了孔雀巷酒吧。我们进去了。那家伙看了我一眼，说，你真的……因为我看起来太年轻了。但最终他让我进了。他让我进了。当那个乐队开始演奏时，他们太棒了。他们太棒了。迈尔斯看起来那么讲究，那么酷，我完全被震慑住了。
And so I told my cousin, who went with us, that I wanted to go up and say hello to Miles and tell him how much I loved his music. And so my cousin said, "Quincy, don't go up and say nothing to Miles, because Miles doesn't talk to people. He doesn't like people coming up to him and talking to him. So don't go up to him and say anything. Just look at him from a distance."
我告诉和我一起去的表亲，我想过去跟迈尔斯打个招呼，告诉他我有多爱他的音乐。于是表亲说：“昆西，别过去跟迈尔斯说话，因为迈尔斯不跟人聊天。他不喜欢人们跑过去跟他套近乎。所以别过去说什么。就在远处看着他就行。”
So we kind of stood back and looked at him from a distance, all of us. It was a whole bunch of us, young guys and older guys. We had our glasses and everything on like he had his glasses on. And we kind of looked at him standing at the bar, smoking a cigarette, drinking a cognac. And from behind us someplace, I heard this voice say, "Oh, darling, there's Miles Davis."
所以我们站在远处看着他。我们有好几个人，有年轻人也有年长的。我们都戴着墨镜，就像他戴着墨镜一样。我们看着他站在吧台边，抽着烟，喝着白兰地。然后我身后传来一个声音说：“哦，亲爱的，那是迈尔斯·戴维斯。”
And I turned around, and it was this white guy with his girlfriend. And I said, "Whoa, what is he going to do?" He said, "Let's go up and say hello." So he walked through us, "Excuse me, excuse me." And he walked up to Miles Davis, who was standing at the bar with Coltrane and all him. He said, "Hi, Miles. How are you?" And Miles said in that gruff voice, "Eff you. Get out of my face," like that.
我转过身，是一个白人带着他的女朋友。我说：“哇，他要干嘛？”他说：“我们过去打个招呼吧。”于是他穿过我们，“借过，借过。”他走到正站在吧台边与科尔特兰及其他人在一起的迈尔斯·戴维斯面前。他说：“嘿，迈尔斯。你好吗？”迈尔斯用那种沙哑的声音说：“去你的。离我远点。”就这样。
And I was like, "Wow." That was stunning. I had never heard anybody talk to anyone like that, let alone an African-American man say that to a white guy. And I just said to myself, "Man, this is something."
我当时想，“哇。”这太让人震惊了。我从来没听过有人那样对别人说话，更不用说是一个非裔美国男人对白人那样说。我对自己说：“天呐，这真有意思。”
Now, when was the first time you met Miles as an adult, as the person who you are now?
那么，你作为成年人，作为今天的你，第一次见到迈尔斯是什么时候？
Yes. I was living in New York. And my friend, Leo Maitland, who is now deceased, was a doctor. And he was Miles' doctor. And he used to always say to me, "I know Miles Davis." I said, "You got to introduce me to Miles. You got to introduce me to Miles."
是的。当时我住在纽约。我的朋友，利奥·梅特兰（现已去世），是一名医生。他也是迈尔斯的医生。他经常对我说：“我认识迈尔斯·戴维斯。”我说：“你一定要把我介绍给迈尔斯。你一定要把我介绍给他。”
So one day, he said, "I'm going to have this party." And I said, "OK." "You want to come?" I said, "Yeah." So I go to the party. And I walk in, and I'm sitting around. And he had this great apartment. And I look over in the corner, and there's Miles Davis. I said, "My god, Miles Davis." And there was nobody sitting next to him. His was the only seat in the house with nobody sitting next to him. So I went and got some food and I looked around, no place to sit, and went into another room, there wasn't no place to sit. I came back, there was this seat.
有一天，他说：“我要办个派对。”我说：“好。”“你想来吗？”我说：“想。”于是我去参加了派对。我走进去，坐在那儿。他那公寓很棒。我朝角落看了看，迈尔斯·戴维斯在那儿。我说：“天呐，迈尔斯·戴维斯。”他旁边没人坐。那是全场唯一一个旁边没人坐的位置。于是我拿了些吃的，四处看了看，没位子坐，又去了另一个房间，也没位子。我回来时，那个位置还空着。
So I went and sat next to Miles. So I remember him saying something like, "How are you doing?" I said, "Hi. All right." "Yeah, you sure?" I said, "Yeah." He says, "You see anything good in here?" I say, "What?" "Anything, man. I'm talking about do you see anything good?" And I said, "There's some nice ladies in here." "That's right. That's right. You got a good eye."
所以我过去坐在了迈尔斯旁边。我记得他说了一些类似“你怎么样”的话。我说：“嘿。还好。”“是吗，你确定？”我说：“是的。”他说：“你在这儿看见什么好东西了吗？”我说：“什么？”“我是说，伙计，你看到什么好的了吗？”我说：“这儿有些漂亮的女士。”“没错。没错。你眼光不错。”
So I said, "Yeah, I love your music." "I don't want to talk about my music. I don't want to talk about it." I said, "OK." So then we had this general conversation. And then he went and got some food, came back, said to me, "Later." And he left.
我说：“是啊，我爱你的音乐。”“我不想谈我的音乐。我不想谈它。”我说：“好的。”于是我们进行了一次随意的交谈。后来他去拿了些吃的，回来时对我说：“回头见。”然后他就走了。
So about two weeks later, I was walking down this--
大概两周后，我正走在……
Wait, wait. Can we just hold on that part of the conversation? Was this a kind of nervous moment for you? I mean, you're sitting there next to Miles Davis. What was your feeling during this conversation?
等等，等等。我们能暂停一下吗？在那段谈话中，你当时紧张吗？我是说，你坐在迈尔斯·戴维斯旁边。你当时的感受是什么？
I was totally up for it. I had no fear in talking to him, I guess, maybe, because by this time, I was starting to get a little play myself, as a writer, in New York. I was starting to get some ink. And I had a kind of feeling about myself at that point. And so it was funny. We just kind of had this exchange. And then when he got ready to leave, he just left. He just left. But he came over to me and said, "Later." So I thought it was some kind of indication that he liked the conversation or whatever.
我完全准备好了。我猜测也许是因为那时作为一名纽约的作家，我也开始崭露头角，有了一些名声。在那一刻，我对自己有一种自信。所以这很有趣。我们只是进行了这种交流。当他准备离开时，他就那样走了。他就那么走了。但他走过来对我说：“回头见。”所以我认为这是一种他喜欢这次谈话的暗示，什么的。
And so about three weeks later, I was walking down Broadway. And here he comes walking straight towards me. And I said, "Oh, that's Miles Davis." So when he got up next to me, I said, "Hey, Miles. How you doing?" He walked right by me. Like I didn't even exist. Like I wasn't even on the planet. I mean, he didn't even nod, or nothing. He just walked right by me.
大概三周后，我走在百老汇大道上。他径直朝我走过来。我说：“哦，那是迈尔斯·戴维斯。”当他走到我身边时，我说：“嘿，迈尔斯。你好吗？”他径直从我身边走过。就好像我根本不存在一样。就像我根本不在这个星球上。我是说，他连头都没点，什么都没做。他直接走过去了。
And I stopped. I remember stopping, and I kind of looked back and said, "Wow, was that Miles Davis?" And it was. I said, "Yeah, that's him. But he didn't speak." I said, "Hey, Miles." And he didn't even turn around. He just kept going. So I said, "Wow, that was kind of cold." I mean, that was kind of cold. It was like, I had never experienced that before in my life.
我停了下来。我记得当时停住了，回头看了看，说：“哇，那是迈尔斯·戴维斯吗？”确实是他。我说：“没错，是他。但他没理我。”我说：“嘿，迈尔斯。”他甚至都没回头。他只是继续往前走。我说：“哇，这可真够冷淡的。”我是说，这也太冷淡了。那是我一生中从未经历过的感觉。
And so when I got to know him, I finally got to know him real well, when I did the Spin Magazine . I did a two-part piece for Spin Magazine. And when I walked in his place, he looked at me and he kind of said, "Yeah, sit down." So I sit down. And I remember him reaching out with his hand to grab my dreadlocks. And I hit his hand. Pow. And he said, "What are you, crazy? What are you crazy, hitting me like that?"
后来我真正认识他是在我为《Spin》杂志写稿时。我为《Spin》杂志做了一篇两部分的专题。当我走进他住处时，他看着我，说：“嗯，坐下吧。”我坐下了。我记得他伸手要去抓我的脏辫。我一把拍掉了他的手。啪。他说：“你疯了吗？你疯了吗，那样打我？”
I said, "No, man." I said, "Because I'm over here to interview you doesn't mean that you have the right to invade my space." I said, "Plus, the other times that I tried to talk to you, you just shined me on." He said, "Oh, you mean the time out on the street? The time out on the street?" I said, "Yeah." He said, "Man, I don't have to talk to you, man. I didn't have to talk to you. What you got to talk about this time?"
我说：“不，伙计。我是来采访你的，但这并不意味着你有权侵犯我的私人空间。”我说：“况且，之前我试图跟你说话的时候，你总对我冷处理。”他说：“哦，你是说在街上的那次？在街上的那次？”我说：“对。”他说：“伙计，我没必要跟你聊天。我不需要跟你说话。你这次有什么要谈的？”
And that's the way it started. And we got to be the best of friends until he died. But Miles was always testing you. He was always testing you. He was the kind of guy-- and I loved him because he was always the kind of a guy that was always testing you. And if you passed the muster, if you could stand up to him, then if he liked you, he would bring you in. If you couldn't, he'd just run over you, you know?
事情就是这样开始的。我们就成了最好的朋友，直到他去世。但迈尔斯总是试图考验你。他总是考验你。他就是那种人——我爱他，因为他总是那样——他总是会考验你。如果你通过了考验，如果你能顶得住他，而且如果他喜欢你，他就会带你进去。如果你不行，他就会直接把你碾碎，你懂吗？
More with Miles Davis and Quincy Troupe. Also Snuggles the fabric softener bear and 1,000 Selenas. That's in a minute, from Public Radio International when our program continues.
更多关于迈尔斯·戴维斯和昆西·特鲁普的内容。还有Snuggles柔顺剂熊和《一千个塞琳娜》。稍后为您播出，节目继续，来自公共广播国际。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Quincy Troupe spent three years collaborating with Miles Davis on Davis' autobiography, talking to Davis and interviewing him, actually, until Davis got sick of being interviewed, to create a book written in Miles' voice and syntax. It sold over 1 million copies. And if you ask Quincy, when did he stop seeing Miles Davis as the mythic, legendary figure and start seeing him as just another friend, he really can't tell you. It was gradual. One day he was on the outside of Miles' life looking in. And then at some point later, he realized that he was on the inside.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。昆西·特鲁普与迈尔斯·戴维斯合作了三年，撰写戴维斯的自传。他与戴维斯交谈、采访他，直到戴维斯厌倦了接受采访，最终以迈尔斯的语调和句法完成了这本书。销量超过了100万册。如果你问昆西，他是什么时候停止把迈尔斯·戴维斯视为神话般的传奇人物，而开始仅仅把他当作又一个朋友的，他真的说不出来。那是渐进的过程。有一天他还在迈尔斯生活的圈子之外往里看。后来在某个时刻，他意识到自己已经在圈子内部了。
You know, I got very up close with Miles. I mean, I was in his pocket and he was in my pocket for two and a half, three years. Until the time he died. I mean, I was really close to him. And so I saw flaws in his personality that-- because I think when you idolize a person like him-- like he was one of my heroes-- especially when you're young, you don't think they have flaws. You kind of see them through these rose-tinted glasses. And you kind of look at them as perfect.
你知道吗，我和迈尔斯非常亲近。我的意思是，我和他形影不离地相处了两三年。直到他去世。我是说，我真的和他很亲近。所以我看到了他性格中的缺陷——因为我认为当你崇拜像他这样的人时——他曾是我的偶像之一——尤其是当你还年轻的时候，你不会认为他们有任何缺点。你戴着玫瑰色的眼镜看他们。你觉得他们是完美的。
And so when I started to see some things that was not perfect about Miles, like his way of treating women and his way of treating other people sometimes and little small things, like cleanliness sometimes.
所以当我开始发现迈尔斯一些不完美的地方时，比如他对待女性的方式，有时他对待其他人的方式，还有一些小事，比如有时不爱干净。
You know, cleanliness is coming up in this interview a lot more than I ever would have guessed.
你知道，在这个采访中，关于爱不爱干净这个问题出现的频率比我预想的要高得多。
Well, Miles was a clean person. In terms of his body and the way he dressed, but there were a couple of times when I went over his house one day-- I went over to his house one day, and it was a mess. I mean, stuff was everywhere. Clothes, toothbrush, toothpaste, music, trumpets.
嗯，迈尔斯是个讲究的人。就他的身体和穿着而言，但有几次我有一天去他家——我有一天去他家，那简直是一团糟。我是说，东西到处都是。衣服、牙刷、牙膏、乐谱、小号。
And I said, "Miles, man," I said, "Miles, you living like a pig, man." I said, "You're living like a pig, man. This is a pigsty." He said, "So what? So what? So what, it's a pigsty? What did you expect? I just play music, chump." He said, "Somebody cleans it up. That's the deal."
我说：“迈尔斯，老兄，”我说，“迈尔斯，你活得像头猪，伙计。”我说，“你活得像头猪。这简直是个猪圈。”他说：“那又怎样？那又怎样？是猪圈又怎样？你指望什么？我只是演奏音乐，笨蛋。”他说：“有人会打扫的。就是这样。”
Well, I would see some of that. And first I would say, man this guy could be a pig, you know? But then, I got to the point where I said, no, he's just a human being. He's a human being. He has flaws. He plays beautiful music. But he had these little areas where he was just a human being, where he was flawed. Like, I never thought Miles would be as country as he was. You know, what I mean by country. I mean country-country, like a Southern-- instead of a jazz musician, when you got to know Miles, like some elegant jazz musician, Miles was like a country blues singer.
嗯，我会看到其中的一些情况。起初我会想，天哪，这家伙怎么能这么邋遢，你知道吗？但后来，我意识到，不，他只是个人。他是一个人。他有缺陷。他演奏着美妙的音乐。但他确实在这些小地方表现得像个普通人，有瑕疵。比如，我从没想过迈尔斯会那么“乡土气”。你知道我说的“乡土气”是什么意思。我是说非常接地气，像个南方人——当你了解迈尔斯时，他不像一位优雅的爵士乐手，迈尔斯更像一位乡村蓝调歌手。
When was it that you first saw that side of him really clearly?
你是什么时候第一次真正清楚地看到他那一面的？
When I was doing the book, and I was about three or four months in, when he started dropping the mask. And he'd just drop the mask. And I'd come by, and he'd have food. And he'd cook for me. And we'd look at boxing matches and look at the basketball games. And at first, when I would go over there, he would always be dressed elegantly in very fashionable stuff. And then after that, he started dressing just really casually. And especially on the West Coast. When I'd go up there, he'd have on blue jeans, a torn sweater. And he would just cook. And we'd just sit there and look and tell lies. And he'd listen to the fights. And we'd go for long walks on the beach. And he'd take me for rides in his car.
在我写那本书的时候，大概进行了三四个月，他开始摘下面具了。他会随手摘下面具。我过去的时候，他会有食物。他会给我做饭。我们会看拳击比赛和篮球比赛。起初，当我过去的时候，他总是打扮得很优雅，穿得很时髦。后来，他开始穿得很随意。特别是在西海岸的时候。当我过去时，他会穿着蓝色牛仔裤，一件破毛衣。他会做饭。我们就坐在那里看着，吹吹牛。他会听拳击比赛。我们会去海边散步。他会开车带我兜风。
So it was just a beautiful kind of relationship. As a matter of fact, I told him, I said, "You know, when you're in California, you're much different than you are in New York." And he said, "Yeah." After a while, he acknowledged that. He said, "Yeah, because in New York, I've got to keep my mask up." I said, "Yeah, that's right. You got to keep it up."
所以那真是一种美好的关系。事实上，我告诉他，我说：“你知道吗，你在加州的时候，和你住在纽约时非常不同。”他说：“是啊。”过了一会儿，他承认了。他说：“没错，因为在纽约，我必须戴着面具。”我说：“是的，没错。你必须戴着它。”
When did you first figure out about the way he was treating women? When did you first figure out that he was kind of abusive?
你是什么时候第一次发现他对待女性的方式的？你是什么时候第一次发现他有点虐待倾向的？
Well, when I started to hear some of the stories. Because Miles was brutally honest. He was brutally honest when he did that book. I remember he was telling me the stories of him beating up these women and chasing his wife around the basement of their house with a knife and a gun. And so I started to think to myself, wow, this is ouch. I mean, this is a strange kind of situation, because I'm just the opposite. I don't believe in hitting women. I don't believe in hitting anybody like that.
嗯，当我开始听到一些故事的时候。因为迈尔斯极其坦诚。他在写那本书时非常坦诚。我记得他跟我讲了他殴打这些女性，拿着刀和枪在房子地下室追赶他妻子的故事。所以我也开始想，哇，这真是太糟糕了。我的意思是，这是一种很奇怪的情况，因为我恰恰相反。我不相信打女人。我不相信那样打任何人。
But I figured out that Miles Davis was the kind of person-- he wasn't an intellectual, where he could respond and talk it out, talk the whole thing through. So if you got up in his face, whether you were a man or a woman, he would hit you. That was the way he was. I mean, he would hit you.
但我明白迈尔斯·戴维斯就是那种人——他不是个知识分子，无法回应并谈论一切，把事情说清楚。所以如果你当面挑衅他，无论你是男人还是女人，他都会打你。他就是那样的人。我的意思是，他会动手打你。
I can be truthful and say I didn't like the way he did certain things. But then at the same time, we who knew him really well knew that he was a warm and generous person to us. And we'd look at those things and say, hey man, that was kind of cold what he did there. But the way I looked at it, I'd say, well, that's between him and that person.
我可以诚实地说，我不喜欢他处理某些事情的方式。但与此同时，我们这些真正了解他的人都知道，他对我们很热情慷慨。我们会看着那些事情说，嘿伙计，他那样做太冷酷了。但我看待它的方式是，嗯，那是他和那个人之间的事情。
I never saw him hit a woman in front of me. Because you've got to remember, I knew him from 1985 until he died, which was a period of six years. And so when he was in his most desperately insane period of really doing these kind of things to women, this was from 1968 to 1980, 12 years. And I didn't know him then. So I never saw that.
我从没见过他在我面前打女人。因为你要记住，我从1985年认识他直到他去世，那是六年的时间。所以当他处于那种对他对待女性的行为最疯狂的时期时，那是1968年到1980年，那是12年的时间。那时我不认识他。所以我从未见过。
Would there be an occasional moment sometimes, once you got to be friends with him, where it would suddenly strike you, man, I'm friends with Miles Davis?
当你和他成为朋友后，是否有那么一瞬间，你会突然意识到，天哪，我是迈尔斯·戴维斯的亲友？
When it would generally happen was when somebody would come up to me and say to me, "Man, what is it like to be with Miles Davis? You know, I always wanted to be with Miles Davis." And then I would think, whoa.
通常发生在有人走到我面前对我说：“老兄，和迈尔斯·戴维斯在一起是什么感觉？你知道，我一直想和迈尔斯·戴维斯待在一起。”那时我才会想，哇。
But for me, after it got to a certain level, I never thought about it. Because we just had this natural relationship. He'd call me up or I'd call him up.
但对我来说，达到一定程度后，我就没再想过这件事。因为我们只是有着一种自然的关系。他会打电话给我，或者我打电话给他。
I remember telling somebody one time, Miles called me up from Japan. He had just taped this new thing. And he said, "What do you think of this?" And he put it on. And he played for about five minutes. And he said, "What did you think?" And I would tell him whether I liked it or I didn't. If I didn't like it, I would tell him I didn't like it. And I was relating this to somebody. And they said, "You mean Miles Davis calls you up, and puts on the tape, and you listen to it?" And I said, "Yeah." He says, "Well, what's that like?" I said, "I guess it's like any one of my friends who is a poet, who will say 'listen to this poem,' you know what I mean? It just so happens it's Miles Davis' music, and he happens to be internationally famous."
我记得有一次告诉某人，迈尔斯从日本给我打电话。他刚录好这首新曲子。他说：“你觉得这个怎么样？”然后他播放了。他放了大约五分钟。他说：“你觉得怎么样？”我会告诉他我喜欢还是不喜欢。如果我不喜欢，我会直接告诉他。我当时正和别人说起这件事。他们说：“你是说迈尔斯·戴维斯打电话给你，放磁带给你听？”我说：“是啊。”他说：“那是什么感觉？”我说：“我想这就像我任何一个写诗的朋友，说‘听听这首诗’，你明白吗？碰巧这是迈尔斯·戴维斯的音乐，而且他碰巧是个国际巨星。”
Many public figures up close lose the larger-than-life quality that they seem to have from afar. But there's something about Miles Davis that even today, even though Quincy Troupe was as close to Miles Davis as he's ever been to anybody in his life, that even today it's easy for Quincy to see Miles as this mythic figure. He says Miles just had this effect on people.
许多公众人物近距离接触后，会失去远看时那种超凡脱俗的品质。但迈尔斯·戴维斯身上有一些特质，即使在今天，尽管昆西·特鲁普是他一生中接触过最亲近的人，即使在今天，昆西依然很容易将迈尔斯视为一个神话般的人物。他说迈尔斯对人就有这种影响力。
I remember one time, I was with him-- I can't remember the Japanese, it was not [? Miashi, ?] but it was another Japanese designer. And he had his clothes in New York. And he had his clothes, and he had Andy Warhol, before Andy Warhol died, and Miles Davis modeling as the star models of the clothes, along with all these beautiful, gorgeous women. So Miles called me and said, "Do you want to go down with me?" I said, "Yeah, I'll go with you."
我记得有一次，我和他在一起——我不记得那个日本设计师的名字了，不是[？Miashi？]，是另一位日本设计师。他在纽约发布服装。他有他的衣服，还有安迪·沃霍尔——在安迪·沃霍尔去世之前，以及迈尔斯·戴维斯作为服装的首席模特，还有许多美丽动人的女性。所以迈尔斯打电话给我说：“你想跟我一起去吗？”我说：“好啊，我跟你去。”
So we go in this place called The Tunnel. It was some kind of a discotheque. So we're in there and they're modeling the clothes, and everybody's going out. Miles would walk out. Andy Warhol would walk out. So I'm backstage with Andy. And these are two legends. These are two American icons in culture. So Miles was the finale. And he had this outfit with this gold lame cape that he was supposed to walk out, with a hat.
于是我们去了那个叫“隧道”的地方。那是一种迪斯科舞厅。我们在那儿，他们正在展示服装，每个人都在往外走。迈尔斯走了出来。安迪·沃霍尔走了出来。我和安迪在后台。这两个都是传奇。这两个是美国文化的偶像。迈尔斯是压轴。他穿着一套带金丝披风的衣服，戴着帽子。
So he started to walk out. And Andy was standing there looking at him. And the cape was dragging on the floor. So he started to walk out. And he turned around and looked at Andy Warhol. And he said, "Andy, Andy. Pick up that cape." So Andy picked up the cape and they walked out together, you know what I mean? And Andy had this sheepish look on his face.
他开始走出去。安迪站在那里看着他。披风拖在地板上。于是他开始走出去。他转过身看着安迪·沃霍尔。他说：“安迪，安迪。捡起那个披风。”于是安迪捡起了披风，他们一起走了出去，你懂我的意思吗？安迪脸上露出一种羞怯的神情。
And Miles strutted out, and Andy was holding the cape off the floor. And they walked up the thing. And so everybody in the room-- they left us in the room. Andy's handlers, they were like shocked. They had never heard anything like that. They were like, "Wow, did you see that? Did you see that?" But Andy was smiling. He was happy to be in it. He was happy to be in it.
迈尔斯大步走出去，而安迪在后面帮他拎着披风。他们走上了台。房间里的每个人——他们把我们留在房间里。安迪的助手们，他们惊呆了。他们从未听说过这种事。他们说：“哇，你看到了吗？你看到了吗？”但安迪在笑。他很高兴参与其中。他很高兴参与其中。
And so that was Miles. Miles Davis was almost like a king, you know what I mean? He was like a king. And so that particular moment, I remember his attitude was like, "I'm the king here. Pick up the cape. We both might be icons, but I'm a bigger icon than you."
那就是迈尔斯。迈尔斯·戴维斯几乎就像一位国王，你明白我的意思吗？他就像一位国王。所以那一刻，我记得他的态度就像是，“我才是这里的国王。捡起披风。我们可能都是偶像，但我比你更具代表性。”
Quincy Troupe co-authored Miles Davis' autobiography, Miles. He is a poet and journalist and essayist and author of several books. He latest is called Avalanche from Coffee House Press.
昆西·特鲁普是迈尔斯·戴维斯自传《迈尔斯》的合著者。他是一位诗人、记者、散文家，著有多本书籍。他的最新作品是由Coffee House Press出版的《雪崩》。
Well, now we have this artifact. This is Act Three of our program, Snuggles. From 1980 through 1995, a guy in New York ran what he called an apology line. And the idea is that people would call up. They would call this anonymous line, and they would apologize for anything they believed that they had done that was worthy of apology. Eventually, this guy started to call himself-- or maybe he called himself this from the start-- Mr. Apology. His real name was Allan Bridge.
好吧，现在我们有了这个文物。这是我们节目的第三部分，《亲热熊》。从1980年到1995年，纽约有一个人经营着他所谓的“道歉热线”。想法是人们可以打来电话。他们会拨打这个匿名热线，为他们认为值得道歉的任何事情进行道歉。最终，这个人开始称自己——或者也许他一开始就这么叫——“道歉先生”。他的真名是艾伦·布里奇。
And over time, people would apologize. And some apologies would be real. And some would be fake. And some would be some combination of the two, you couldn't really tell. And then people could call in and respond to the apologies they were hearing as well. Anyway, this particular apology was transcribed in the magazine of the apology line, Apology Magazine , volume one, number four. This is called "Snuggly Bear," from August, 1993. This is a transcription of something somebody said on the phone line.
随着时间的推移，人们会打来道歉。有些道歉是真的。有些是假的。还有些是两者的某种结合，你真的分不清。然后人们还可以打电话进来，回应他们听到的道歉。总之，这个特别的道歉被记录在道歉热线的杂志《道歉杂志》第四期第一卷中。这篇名为“亲热熊”，来自1993年8月。这是某人在电话线上说的话的转录。
"I have an apology to make. And I suppose this is as good a place to do it as any. I was watching TV and a commercial came on. It was a commercial for fabric softener, I believe. It was a small, furry bear, Snuggly Bear. And Snuggly Bear was extolling the virtues of this product, this fabric softener, I believe. And I don't know what it was about this bear, but I was fascinated. Small bear, high-pitched voice, indeterminate sex, not sure if it's male or female. I was fascinated.
“我有一个道歉要说。我想这里是一个很好的地方。我当时在看电视，插播了一个广告。我相信那是一个织物柔顺剂的广告。是一只毛茸茸的小熊，‘亲热熊’。亲热熊正在吹捧这种产品，这种织物柔顺剂，我相信。我不知道这只熊有什么魔力，但我被它迷住了。小熊，尖细的嗓音，性别不明，不确定是雄性还是雌性。我被迷住了。”
"A few days later, another commercial came on again. Once again, I stopped what I was doing and I watched. This time I kept watching and hoped. I kept the station on. I hoped that the commercial would come back. And sure enough, later on in the evening, another commercial came on, a different commercial with the same Snuggly Bear. Same product.
“几天后，广告又播出了。我又一次停下手中的事盯着看。这次我一直盯着看，并心存期待。我一直停留在那个频道。我希望广告能再播一次。果然，那天晚上晚些时候，又播出了一个广告，同样的亲热熊，不同的广告。同样的产品。”
"I went to the supermarket, and I saw the product. And I saw the picture of Snuggly Bear. I purchased the product. I didn't use it to soften any fabrics. I just wanted to have a picture of Snuggly Bear. I wrote Snuggly Bear a letter. And I was hoping for an answer, but I didn't receive one. Then I wrote another one. I was hoping to get some sort of response, a photograph, an autograph, something. Still no response.
“我去超市看到了这个产品。我看到了亲热熊的图片。我买了它。我没用它来柔顺任何织物。我只是想拥有一张亲热熊的图片。我给亲热熊写了一封信。我希望能收到回复，但没有。然后我又写了一封。我希望能得到某种回应，一张照片，一个签名，什么都行。还是没有回应。”
"I wrote a third letter, and I'm afraid I was rather upset when I wrote the letter. I've since learned that the letter was turned over to the FBI. I was warned not to try to contact Snuggly Bear again. Snuggly Bear travels around. I believe the bear has one residence in Martha's Vineyard and another residence on the West Coast. I'm not sure where the West Coast residence is, but I've been to the Martha's Vineyard residence. I let myself in.
“我写了第三封信，我担心我在写这封信时太激动了。后来我才知道那封信被交给了FBI。我被警告不要再试图联系亲热熊。亲热熊四处奔波。我相信这只熊在玛莎葡萄园有一个住所，在西海岸还有另一个。我不确定西海岸的住所具体在哪里，但我去过玛莎葡萄园的住所。我溜了进去。”
There was, of course, a certain amount of security around the house, but I let myself in. I climbed the gate and I found a window open around the back of the house, a rather large house. And I wandered around. He wasn't home, of course. He or she wasn't home. I'm sure he was out on the road doing his pitch for the fabric softener.
“当然，房子周围有一定的安保措施，但我还是溜进去了。我翻过了大门，在房子后面发现了一扇开着的窗户，那是一栋相当大的房子。我四处逛了逛。当然，他不在家。他或她不在家。我相信他一定是在路上为柔顺剂做宣传。”
"Well, if I can only reach Snuggly Bear. If I can only make Snuggly Bear understand that I understand. I'm sure if I get through to Snuggly Bear that I'm sure we could establish a relationship, or just an understanding. But the way it's going now, everything is in limbo. Every time I try to contact this bear, I'm thwarted. I'm calling to apologize, because I guess I've been a bad boy. I'm not stalking Snuggly Bear. They've accused me of stalking Snuggly Bear, but I'm not a stalker. I simply want Snuggly Bear to understand that I understand. That's all. I'm sorry."
“嗯，如果我能联系上亲热熊就好了。如果我能让亲热熊明白我理解他。我相信只要我能联系到亲热熊，我们就能建立某种关系，或者至少是一种理解。但以目前的情况来看，一切都悬而未决。每次我试图联系这只熊，我都会受挫。我打电话来是为了道歉，因为我想我刚才做了一个坏男孩。我没有跟踪亲热熊。他们指控我跟踪亲热熊，但我不是跟踪狂。我只是想让亲热熊知道我理解他。仅此而已。对不起。”
Well, somebody heard that apology on the apology line. And then they called in with this message. "This is out to the man who has the fixation on Snuggles Bear. I do understand, and I would really like to give you my emotional support. I do care. I sort of had a similar experience with McGruff the crime dog. And actually, we managed to get together. I can barely even say his name now.
嗯，有人在道歉热线上听到了那个道歉。然后他们打进这个消息。“这是给那个对亲热熊有执念的人。我理解，而且我真的想给你我的情感支持。我很在意。我和‘犯罪猎犬麦克格鲁夫’有过类似的经历。事实上，我们最终走到了一起。我现在几乎连他的名字都说不出口了。”
"We did manage to get it together. And I got into his life. He accepted me. He cared about me. But you can imagine. You see him all the time on TV. And life with a cop is difficult. I just didn't know when he'd be coming home at night, and I couldn't take it anymore. Plus, he was sort of spraying all over the furniture. Basically, what I want to say to you is maybe loving from afar is the best thing to do. And maybe it's best that you never actually get to meet Snuggles. Because then you'll have this pure, this untainted image of Snuggles. You take care. Bye-bye."
“我们确实在一起了。我进入了他的生活。他接受了我。他在乎我。但你可以想象。你总是能在电视上看到他。和警察的生活很困难。我只是不知道他晚上什么时候会回家，我受不了了。而且，他还在家具上到处乱喷。基本上，我想对你说的是，也许远距离的爱是最好的。也许你永远不要真的见到亲热熊是最好的。因为那样你就会拥有亲热熊那种纯净、未受污染的形象。保重。再见。”
Act Four, 1,000 Women Become Selena. It's one thing to admire someone from afar and try to get close to them. It is another thing to actually try to dress as someone you admire, try to look like them, try to become them, even for a day. Well, that's what happened recently here in Chicago at Clemente High School. Let me get some sound going here.
第四部分，1000个女人成为赛琳娜。远距离欣赏一个人并试图靠近他们是一回事。但试图打扮成你钦佩的人，试图看起来像他们，试图成为他们，哪怕是一天，那是另一回事。嗯，最近在芝加哥的克莱门特高中就发生了这样的事。让我来播放一点声音。
That was a very NPR moment, huh? Picture, please, a gray, cold Chicago day, two lines of women and girls stretched around the block in both directions around this high school. One line is 18 year olds in scanty clothing. Scanty, I guess, would be the appropriate word. The other line is full of eight year olds, many in scanty clothing, though not all. Music blares, people are singing and dancing. And nearly every woman and girl trying out to be the star of the upcoming Selena movie has brought her extended family with her. The director of the film says that he wants to find two Selenas, one to play Selena as a child, one to play Selena as an adult.
那是很典型的一幕，对吧？请想象一下，在寒冷的芝加哥灰色的一天，两条由妇女和女孩组成的队伍在高中周围绕着街区排开了。一条队伍是穿着清凉的18岁女孩。清凉，我想这应该是合适的词。另一条队伍全是8岁的小女孩，许多也穿着清凉，虽然不是全部。音乐震耳欲聋，人们在唱歌跳舞。几乎每一个试图成为即将拍摄的赛琳娜电影主角的女人和女孩都把她的大家庭带在了身边。电影导演说他想找两个赛琳娜，一个扮演童年时代的赛琳娜，一个扮演成年后的赛琳娜。
Selena, or Se-leh-na, was, of course, the Mexican-American pop star recently killed, widely revered. And perhaps you saw footage of these auditions on the news. We decided to send 18-year-old Claudia Perez to cover the event. Claudia loves Selena, and she wanted to audition herself.
赛琳娜，或者Se-leh-na，当然是最近去世的墨西哥裔美国流行歌星，备受崇敬。也许你在新闻中看到了这些试镜的片段。我们决定派18岁的克劳迪娅·佩雷斯去报道这件事。克劳迪娅热爱赛琳娜，她自己也想参加试镜。
12-year-old Jessica [? Letta ?] almost didn't make it. On Friday, she and her family drove seven hours from St. Paul, Minnesota. They arrived late at night and showed up at Clemente High School at 5:30 Saturday morning. Before coming down to Chicago, Jessica's mom told me something terrible had happened.
12岁的杰西卡 [？Letta？] 差点没赶上。周五，她和家人从明尼苏达州的圣保罗开车开了七个小时。他们深夜到达，周六早上5:30出现在克莱门特高中。在来芝加哥之前，杰西卡的妈妈告诉我发生了一件可怕的事。
Yesterday morning that we planned to come here, she was really sick.
昨天早上我们计划来这儿的时候，她病得很重。
I ran down the stairs, she goes--
我跑下楼梯，她说——
High fever. And I said, Jess, we're not going. You're very sick.
高烧。我说，杰西，我们不去了。你病得很重。
I started crying.
我开始哭。
My husband goes, take her to the hospital.
我丈夫说，带她去医院。
This is yesterday?
这是昨天的事吗？
That was yesterday. And look at her now.
那是昨天。你看看她现在这样。
My grandpa was scolding my Ma. You better take her to that concert or I'm going to hit her. My grandpa is just a lovable man. He told me to go and he wished me the best of luck. And he goes, even if you're sick, you've got to go. You've got to go. I want to see you win. And I'm like, Grandpa, there is a lot of people that can win. Not just me.
我爷爷在责骂我妈。你最好带她去那个演唱会，否则我要打她。我爷爷是个可爱的老人。他告诉我要去，祝我好运。他说，即使你生病了，你也要去。你必须去。我想看到你赢。我说，爷爷，有很多人都能赢。不只是我。
To hear the family tell it, it's like a miracle that Jessica got well. It was like she was chosen. In fact, Jessica was chosen once before. When Selena was still alive, Jessica and her family were at a concert in [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. She and her mom were standing outside the backstage entrance. And Selena's sister, Suzette, picked Jessica out of a huge crowd of little girls to have her picture taken with Selena.
听到这个家庭的讲述，杰西卡康复简直是个奇迹。就像她是命中注定的。事实上，杰西卡以前就被选中过一次。当赛琳娜还活着的时候，杰西卡和她的家人在[无法辨认]的一场演唱会上。她和她妈妈站在后台入口外面。赛琳娜的姐姐苏泽特在一大群小女孩中挑中了杰西卡，让她和赛琳娜合影。
After I took the picture with Selena, the guard that was standing by the door, the guard goes, I'll give you this picture that you took with Selena for $5. And I'm like, I don't have any money on me right now, but if I go back to table, I can. And they were joking around. Suzette goes, no, no, no, $2. And then Selena turned around and goes, no, I know how much. She goes, for nothing. You can just keep it for free. And I started laughing.
拍完照片后，站在门口的警卫说，我把这张你和赛琳娜的合影给你，5美元。我说，我现在身上没钱，但如果我回到桌子旁，我可以付。他们当时在开玩笑。苏泽特说，不，不，不，2美元。然后赛琳娜转过身说，不，我知道多少钱。她说，不要钱。你可以免费拿去。我就笑了。
Jessica is a beautiful little girl. She has long black hair and a cinnamon complexion. She's wearing a Selena outfit, knee-length boots, spandex hot pants, and a black, padded bustier with gold trimming over the breast. It's Jessica's dream to be like Selena. She wants to be a singer and sing in English and Spanish. She came to the auditions, but not just so she could be a movie star. It's like she wants to feel closer to Selena.
杰西卡是个漂亮的小女孩。她留着长长的黑发，有着肉桂色的皮肤。她穿着赛琳娜的服装，及膝长靴，氨纶热裤，还有一件带金色饰边的黑色衬垫胸衣。成为像赛琳娜那样的人是杰西卡的梦想。她想成为一名歌手，用英语和西班牙语演唱。她来参加试镜，不仅仅是为了成为电影明星。就像她是想感觉离赛琳娜更近一些。
I don't want to do the movie for money or anything. Because money's not the answer. Money's not everything. Look at what it brought to Selena, nothing. I mean, I want to do it because I want Selena to see me, what I'm doing. I just want to do it for Selena.
我不想为了钱什么的去拍电影。因为钱不是答案。钱不是一切。看看它给赛琳娜带来了什么，什么都没有。我的意思是，我想这样做是因为我想让赛琳娜看到我，看到我在做什么。我只想为了赛琳娜去做。
A lot of people still cry over Selena. She was so lovable, just her smile. She was like a little girl. When she went to the Grammy Awards, she went there with her camera, wanted to take pictures with everybody. Selena put a positive role. She made it seem like it's not bad to be Mexican-American. I asked Jessica in Spanish how she felt about Selena's death. She started crying.
很多人仍然为赛琳娜哭泣。她太可爱了，仅仅是她的微笑。她就像个小女孩。当她去参加格莱美奖时，她带着相机去了，想和每个人合影。赛琳娜树立了一个积极的榜样。她让人们觉得做墨西哥裔美国人没什么不好。我用西班牙语问杰西卡她对赛琳娜的去世有什么感觉。她开始哭。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Then I started crying too.
然后我也开始哭了。
She is my best friend. And a lot of people say things that aren't true. And the people don't know how she is. And she was a very nice person. She was a very nice person. Because I met Suzette, and I met her. And they were talking to me and it was-- I mean, I was so happy.
她是我最好的朋友。很多人说些不属实的话。人们不知道她是什么样的人。她是一个非常好的人。她是一个非常好的人。因为我见过苏泽特，也见过她。她们和我说话，那真是——我的意思是，我太高兴了。
After Selena's death, Jessica and her family went to visit her grave in Corpus Christi, Texas.
赛琳娜去世后，杰西卡和她的家人去德克萨斯州科珀斯克里斯蒂市拜祭她的墓。
I was sitting down, and I was hugging the grave, and I asked myself, how come you died, and this and that? And I sang to her. I think I sang "Como la Flor" because it reminds me of her.
我坐在那儿，抱着墓碑，我问自己，你为什么会死，这个那个的？我为她唱了歌。我想我唱的是《Como la Flor》，因为它让我想起了她。
Sing a little part of it.
唱一小段吧。
[SINGING IN SPANISH]
[用西班牙语演唱]
The words mean, "Like the flower with much love, you gave to me. I'll march on. I know how to lose a love. But oh my, how it hurts me."
歌词的意思是，“就像那朵花，带着你给我的许多爱。我会继续前进。我知道如何失去一份爱。但是噢，老天，那有多让我心痛。”
A lot of people say that she might be dead and stuff. But she's not dead. It's that she sleeping. She's sleeping for a very long time. And wherever she is-- in heaven, or wherever-- she's probably singing her heart up there too.
很多人说她可能已经死了之类的话。但她没有死。她只是睡着了。她睡了很长很长的时间。无论她在哪里——天堂，或者是别的地方——她可能也在那上面全心全意地歌唱。
I met all sorts of people at auditions. Everybody was really dressed up and looked fabulous. There was Selena music everywhere, TV cameras, girls were fixing their hair and putting their makeup on. People were dancing. At one point, we were talking to these two girls. They sang us a Selena song. And pretty soon, people we didn't even know were joining in. Everybody was singing. It was just that kind of thing. One of the girls we met came all the way from New York with her mother and her little sister. It was kind of a secret mission.
我在试镜现场见到了各种各样的人。每个人都打扮得漂漂亮亮，看起来棒极了。到处都是赛琳娜的音乐、电视摄像机，女孩们在整理发型、补妆。人们在跳舞。有一次，我们在和两个女孩交谈。她们给我们唱了一首赛琳娜的歌。很快，我们甚至不认识的人也加入了进来。每个人都在唱歌。就是那种氛围。我们遇到的其中一个女孩和她母亲及小妹妹从纽约一路赶来。这像是一个秘密任务。
So your dad's at home?
所以你爸爸在家吗？
Yeah, he doesn't even know we're here.
对，他甚至不知道我们在这里。
No. He doesn't know that?
不。他不知道？
The mother told her husband that she was at a Mary Kay conference in Philadelphia and that the daughters would be spending the weekend at their older sister's house. Then she flew them all to Chicago for the auditions.
这位母亲告诉丈夫她去费城参加玛丽凯会议，女儿们周末会在姐姐家度过。然后她把她们都飞到了芝加哥参加试镜。
Yeah, that's good. Mama saved her daughters.
是啊，那挺好的。妈妈保护了她的女儿们。
My daughters first.
我的女儿优先。
When you finally get inside to the audition, it's kind of disappointing. It's like it's over before it starts. There were 20 girls on the stage at a time. They sit you down at these tables, give you this fake smile, hand you a card to fill out, ask you one question, then tell you to stand up and dance. You dance for 30 seconds. Sometimes they don't even play music. When I went up there, the woman running my table didn't even know who Selena was. She didn't bother to look at me. When we were dancing, they only gave you 60 seconds total to make an impression. So what are they looking for?
当你最终进入试镜现场时，有点令人失望。感觉还没开始就结束了。舞台上一次有20个女孩。他们让你坐在桌子旁，给你一个虚伪的微笑，给你一张卡片让你填写，问你一个问题，然后让你站起来跳舞。你跳30秒。有时他们甚至不放音乐。我上去的时候，负责我们桌子的那个女人甚至不知道赛琳娜是谁。她懒得看我一眼。跳舞时，他们一共只给你60秒的时间来留下印象。所以他们到底在找什么？
Magic.
魔法。
What kind of magic?
什么样的魔法？
Well, I don't know. That special magic that made Selena that-- she was very outgoing, an incredible entertainer, very gifted, very beautiful.
嗯，我不知道。那种让赛琳娜成为她的那种特殊魔法——她非常外向，是一位了不起的艺人，非常有天赋，非常漂亮。
This is the director Greg Nava. He told me there were three auditions, in LA, Chicago, and in Texas. I thought, if he wants magic, I'll give him magic. I told him about Jessica. Of everyone I interviewed, she had the pizazz. She looked like Selena, she had big dreams like Selena, and she has Selena in her heart.
这位是导演格雷格·纳瓦。他告诉我一共有三场试镜，在洛杉矶、芝加哥和德克萨斯。我想，如果他想要魔法，我就给他魔法。我跟他说了杰西卡的事。在我采访的所有人中，她最有活力。她长得像赛琳娜，有着像赛琳娜一样伟大的梦想，而且她的心里装着赛琳娜。
I want to show you this little girl. I don't know if you've seen her.
我想给你看看这个小女孩。不知道你有没有见过她。
Oh, she's beautiful. Fantastic.
哦，她真漂亮。太棒了。
She came.
她来了。
Is she here?
她在这儿吗？
She left already. She told me that she wants to be Selena. She made me cry. And she doesn't even want to get paid.
她已经走了。她告诉我她想成为赛琳娜。她让我哭了。而且她甚至不想拿钱。
I guarantee you, if she gets the role of Selena, she will be paid.
我向你保证，如果她得到了赛琳娜的角色，她一定会得到报酬的。
I thought that maybe the auditions were just a publicity stunt, not serious auditions, something Selena definitely would not approve of. But the director said they will most likely pick the little girl from the open auditions. And there was a 50/50 chance they'd pick the big Selena.
我原以为试镜可能只是个噱头，不是认真的试镜，这是赛琳娜绝对不会赞同的。但导演说他们很可能会从公开试镜中挑选那个小女孩。而且他们有一半的机会选出一个大的赛琳娜。
After a long day, the crowds are cleared. Two cousins who flew in from Texas were sitting outside in the cold, eating pizza, and waiting for a Chicago family friend to pick them up. They had arrived early in the morning and didn't get much sleep. They weren't sure when their ride was coming or where they were going to spend the night. I asked them what they thought of the auditions.
漫长的一天结束后，人群散去了。两位从德克萨斯州飞来的表姐妹坐在寒风中吃着披萨，等待一位芝加哥的世交来接她们。她们清晨抵达，没怎么睡觉。她们不知道接她们的车什么时候到，也不知道今晚要在哪里过夜。我问她们对这次试镜有什么看法。
I don't know. I don't think it went as great as I thought it would be.
我不知道。我觉得表现得没有我预想的那么好。
Yeah, but why? What did you expect?
是吗，为什么呢？你原本期待的是什么？
Well, because, it's like, I don't think the producers were there when I got to do my stuff. So I don't know. I don't know. They're looking for something different. I don't know.
嗯，因为，就好像，我轮到表演的时候制作人好像不在场。所以我不知道。我不知道。他们在找一些与众不同的东西。我不知道。
What makes you think that they're looking for something different?
是什么让你觉得他们在寻找与众不同的东西？
Just because the people that they choose, they talk to, they don't even-- I don't know. Their appearance. They're not looking for more deeply. They're not looking for a true Selena. They're just looking for appearances. And it's really bad. They might know who Selena was, but not truly what she meant to us.
就因为他们选择的人，还有他们交谈的对象，他们甚至……我不知道。只看外表。他们没有深入去发掘。他们找的不是真正的赛琳娜。他们只是在寻找外在形象。这真的很糟糕。他们或许知道赛琳娜是谁，但并不真正了解她对我们意味着什么。
They had spent $135 each, saved from babysitting, to get to Chicago. But they didn't feel bad.
她们每人花了135美元，那是她们从当保姆赚来的钱，才得以来到芝加哥。但她们并不感到难过。
It's fine because we got to meet a lot of people and stuff. I mean, we just came. And we knew we're going to not get picked. But we still came and take the chance, because that's the thing that Selena would always say. If you have a thing, you go for it. Don't let nobody put you down because they say, well, we already chose the person. Give whatever you have. And that's what we did. So that's a reason why we came here.
没关系，因为我们认识了很多人之类的。我的意思是，我们只是来了。我们知道自己不会被选上。但我们还是来了，尝试了一下，因为赛琳娜总是那样说。如果你有心仪的目标，就要去追求。不要因为别人说“我们已经选定人了”就让你气馁。拿出你所拥有的。这就是我们做的。所以这就是我们来这里的原因。
They just sat there on the bench waiting. They weren't really dressed for Chicago weather. They wore fishnet pantyhose, real short shorts, bustiers, and thin leather jackets. You could tell they were really cold. They were anxious for their ride to show up.
她们坐在长椅上等着。她们穿的衣服根本不适合芝加哥的天气。她们穿着网眼连裤袜、超短裤、胸衣和薄皮夹克。你能看出来她们真的很冷。她们焦急地等待着接她们的车出现。
A couple weeks later, it was announced that none of the girls from the open auditions were chosen for the Selena part. Not them, not me, not Jessica. Nobody.
几周后，消息公布，公开试镜的女孩中没有一人被选中出演赛琳娜。不是她们，不是我，也不是杰西卡。没人入选。
Are you doing something tonight?
你今晚有什么安排吗？
We don't know. We have to get a ride first here. And then we'll know where to go. Well, give me a pen. I could give you some places. You can call me. Go to some party.
我们不知道。我们得先搭上车。然后我们才会知道去哪里。好吧，给我一支笔。我可以给你几个地方。你可以打电话给我。去参加某个派对。
Claudia Perez is an 18-year-old former high school dropout who recently got her high school equivalency, hopes to go to the Art Institute of Chicago in the fall, is looking for a full-time job right now. This is her second report for our program. She says she wants to be famous, but up until now we are the best that she can do.
克劳迪娅·佩雷斯是一位18岁的辍学生，她最近获得了高中同等学力证书，希望能进入芝加哥艺术学院深造，目前正在找一份全职工作。这是她为我们节目做的第二篇报道。她说她想出名，但到目前为止，我们已经是她所能接触到的最高平台了。
So Claudia, explain why this is the song you wanted us to play on our program after your story about Selena.
那么克劳迪娅，请解释一下为什么在讲述完你的赛琳娜故事后，你希望我们在节目中播放这首歌。
I like it because she sings it with a mariachi. And it's an old song from Mexico.
我喜欢它，因为她是用墨西哥街头乐队伴奏演唱的。这是一首来自墨西哥的老歌。
When I think of Selena, I don't think of her as a mariachi singer.
当我想到赛琳娜时，我不觉得她是一位墨西哥街头乐队歌手。
Well, you don't. That's why she didn't sing with mariachi. She was more of a beat-y person, with a lot of beat. And that's why this song, this one and this other song that she sang, everybody sang it when she left.
嗯，你确实不觉得。这就是为什么她没有演唱墨西哥街头音乐。她更像是一个有节奏感的人，非常有节奏感。这就是为什么这首歌，还有她唱的另一首歌，在她离世时每个人都在唱。
Everybody sang when she left? You mean everybody sang it when she died?
每个人在她离世时都在唱？你是说每个人在她去世时都在唱？
Yeah.
是的。
Listen to you. You sound like that girl in your story who's like, she's not dead, she's just sleeping, the way you just said that. "When she left." She didn't just leave, honey.
听听你说的。你听起来就像你故事里的那个女孩，她说：“她没有死，她只是睡着了”，你刚才就是那样说的。“当她离世时”。亲爱的，她不仅仅是“离开了”。
I don't like saying death. That's why.
我不喜欢说死亡。就是这样。
[MUSIC - "TU SOLO TU" BY SELENA]
[音乐 - 赛琳娜演唱的《TU SOLO TU》]
Well, today's program was produced by Dolores Wilber and myself with Nancy Updike, Alix Spiegel, and Peter Clowney. Today's show was first broadcast back in 1996. Contributing editors for this show, Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and Margy Rochlin. Margy helped do the reporting and the interviews for our story on Erika Yeomans.
好了，今天的节目由多洛雷斯·威尔伯和我本人制作，参与人员包括南希·厄普代克、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和彼得·克劳尼。今天的节目首播于1996年。本节目的特约编辑有保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特和玛吉·罗克林。玛吉协助完成了我们关于埃里卡·约曼斯的故事的采访和报道。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
To buy a cassette of this or any of our programs, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Or you can visit our website where you can also listen to most of our programs for free, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如需购买本节目或我们任何节目的录音带，请致电芝加哥WBEZ电台，电话312-832-3380。或者您也可以访问我们的网站，在那里您还可以免费收听我们的大部分节目，网址是www.thisamericanlife.org。本节目由公共广播国际（PRI）发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who welcomes his beloved radio staff every single morning to the radio station with this greeting--
WBEZ的管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他每天早上都会用这样一句问候语迎接他心爱的广播团队：
Eff you. Get out of my face.
滚蛋。离我远点。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
Later.
回头见。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。